un autre registre la tenue de deux
comités pilotage mondial de travaux de
restructuration du tunnel judiciaire
visage et dans les mois et les années à
si le premier président de la cour
d'appel de fort-de-france le procureur
général se félicite des excellents
résultats obtenus durant 2019
il reste cependant amer concernant cette
montée de violence en bande organisée en
martinique m
nous avons terminé l'année si j'ose dire
avec 25 comme ici 19 commis par arme à
feu
il ya là une problématique qui interroge
l ensemble de la société martiniquaise
elle peut compter sur nous pour agir
réagir et ne pas rester à attendre mais
je lance un appel comme je lé fais tout
à l'heure à l'action de tous dans ce
cadre un renforcement des moyens et des
effectifs et donc que prévu par la
chancellerie
il ressort que l'engagement des
fonctionnaires des magistrats de cette
juridiction mais aussi du personnel du
service administratif régional a
largement contribué à cette réussite
nous avons des indicateurs pour l'année
2019 qui sont bons nous avons sorti dans
toutes les chambres plus de dossiers qui
dans son antre et nous avons réussi à
réduire des délais traitement des
dossiers
ce n'est pas suffisant mais je tenais à
montrer que les magistrats
fonctionnaires juriste assistantes et
assistants de justice étaient des gens
de qualité qui avait réussi à faire
progresser en un an
un certain nombre de choses j'ai trop de
respect pour le travail de ceux qui
m'ont aidé après un hommage aux avocats
qui ont quitté le barreau de martinique
le tout nouveau bâtonnier de l'ordre des
avocats
philippe chénard justifient leur
position par rapport au projet de
réforme du gouvernement
les annonces qu'ils resteront mobilisés
comme mentionné par ses chefs de cour
2019 a été également l'année d'une
réflexion commune concernant leurs
pratiques au profit du justiciable
martiniquais ses actions de travail
grâce donc les perspectives pour 2020